a curious thing happens at the last
general election in fact a number of
curious things happened but perhaps most
striking was that the class politics
paradigm was in essence turned on its
head the Labour Party made the greatest
gains in seats with the highest
concentrations of wealthy professionals
the Conservatives in the purest seats
south of Gretna Green in essence the
rich were voting for a man who wanted to
tax them more the struggling working
class for the government of austerity
and cuts to public services it's
something of a head scratcher on the
face of it the more an area has
experienced economic decline the worst
labor does the better the Tories perform
indeed fresh analysis from the New
Economics foundation suggests perhaps an
even more fundamental split between the
nation's towns and cities the former
often overlooked even ignored in recent
years in favour of the larger far
shinier centers of wealth creation
because of this economic model this
trickle-down theory that wealth will
trickle down from the cities to the
towns we've seen many of our most valued
community institutions local news agents
community pubs
local libraries on the real real strain
if you go outside of the town centre you
will find that in many areas now they
don't have a local pub they don't have a
local post office these are things that
really matter to people they are the
glue that binds communities together and
they help to give shape and definition
and identity to local communities that's
why there's been such an explosion of
anger and of course cities tended to
vote remain the times to leave often
putting labour on the other side of the
argument from many of their traditional
support I think bricks it was a wake-up
call for mainstream politics that there
are a group of people who feel that
their priorities and values have not
been reflected in British politics for
far too long and actually whoever wins
the towns will win the next election so
this isn't just something that the next
government needs to take seriously this
is something that all parties but
obviously I have a particular interest
in labour we need to take this seriously
right now music to the ears of those
behind Wiggins real junk food projects
also
as for Klimt a local term meaning very
hungry vitac foods destined for landfill
and provided for little or no cost to
the local community an example of the
resourcefulness one often finds in the
shadows cast by the big cities I think
central government of 10 right off the
ball yeah I think generally we feel that
in the north we've been left to one side
our local council is really supportive
helps local projects and helps local
people make a difference to their own
lives but it's not really with any help
from central government the meat and two
veg of the arguments is that all areas
of the region not just the most populous
parts need to tailored specific
attention and potentially eye watering
amounts of investment it can take us
longer to get to Liverpool or Manchester
than it can to London you know so it is
ridiculous when we're crime family
positioned in Wigand smacked between the
two big cities that it can take us an
age to get there because the railways
are poor that the roads are congested so
we need some investment early not in
destruction and of course investment
lots of it in fact is the one thing the
Labour Party is offering that the Tories
are not it's all just a bit
counterintuitive in the same way that
someone with precious little knowledge
of English geography might have expected
to find sea gulls sticks of rock and
kiss me quick hats at Wigan pier of
course you don't
this sees many miles that's a way you
would have thought that in times around
the country labour would be cleaning up
among those struggling blue-collar
workers in this age of austerity and the
fact is they simply aren't having grown
up and live around here all my life and
I know that a lot of people in places
like Wigan are very socially
conservative and now the conservative
course has a values over the years
though where they've traditionally
flocked to the Labour patter because
that's where they felt their home was I
think we've certainly seen a scene
change in the last couple of years since
Jeremy Corbyn took over that he's
increasingly alienated for in these old
traditional supporters and he's talking
the language really that they don't
understand
and compounded with the brexit vote that
we had only only last year where we had
a massive majority to leave in Wigan and
of course the Labour Party you know here
we're all campaigning to stay within the
EU what it certainly isn't all grim
interns up north
neither his life a bed of roses and a
simple belief in a better future just
isn't enough without an effective
strategy the town city divided will
widen and that's an obstacle both
parties need to avoid